[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend in
Israel und den arabischen Nachbarländern
geben sich die westlichen Regierungen
derzeit ja quasi die Klinke in die Hand
Außenminister berburg ist zum zweiten
Mal zu einer Reise in die Region
aufgebrochen ihr Kabinettskollege
pisturius war heute in Israel und auch
bei deutschen Soldaten die in der Region
stationiert sind Deutschland ist ja
beteiligt an der UN-Mission unifiel
sowohl mit einem Marineschiff als auch
mit Blauhelmen am Boden im Südlibanon
sie haben bereits zu spüren bekommen wie
gefährlich die Lage geworden ist letzten
Sonntag schlug eine Rakete neben ihrem
Hauptquartier ein darüber habe ich mit
Boris pisturius vorhin gesprochen nach
seinem Treffen mit dem israelischen
Verteidigungsminister der am Abend seine
Soldaten auf eine Bodenoffensive
einstimmte l walpot
berichtet der Verteidigungsminister zum
Kurzbesuch in Libanon keine politischen
Gespräche stattdessen Austausch mit
marinesoldatinnen und Soldaten Teil der
unifiel Friedensmission Libanon ein
wichtiger Beitrag für die Sicherheit in
der Region so der Minister gerade in
diesen Zeiten weil ich schon glaube dass
gerade jetzt angesichts der Entwicklung
nach dem Terrorangriff der Hamas auf
Israel sich die Situation natürlich
weiter weiter dramatisch entwickeln kann
z.B an der Grenze zwischen Libanon und
Israel seit Tagen gibt es dort
Artilleriebeschuss von beiden Seiten
israel hat mehr als 20 Dörfer entlang
der Grenze evakuiert das Auswärtige Amt
rief heute deutsche Staatsbürger auf den
Libanon zu verlassen auch
Außenministerin bbock ist in der Region
mit den jordanischen Partnern beriz am
Mann über die angespannte Lage über
Hilfen für die palästinensische
Zivilbevölkerung bevor sie morgen nach
Israel weiterreisen wird Terror sei das
Grundübel das bekämpft werden müsse so
berbock aber nicht auf Kosten der
Zivilbevölkerung neues großes Leid unter
der Zivilbevölkerung wird nicht nur den
nähboden für neuen Terrorismus schaffen
sondern auch jegliche bisher erreichten
annäherungsschritte mit den arabischen
Nachbarn in Gefahr bringen genau das ist
das kühl der Terrorist in Gaza gab es
unterdessen weiter israelische
Luftangriffe laut Armee sollen dabei
mehrere hochrangige hamasmitglieder
getötet Kommandozentralen und Tunnel
zerstört worden sein die
palästinensische Seite sprach von
zahlreichen Toten und Verletzten erste
Hilfslieferungen für die notleidende
Bevölkerung sollen morgen von Ägypten in
den Gasastreifen geliefert werden
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius traf am
Nachmittag in Tell seinen israelischen
Amtskollegen Galland Deutschland
unterstütze Israel im Kampf gegen den
Terrorismus so Pistorius es sei aber
auch
wichtig zivile Opfer zu vermeiden wo
immer es möglich ist so wie es das
Völkerrecht für uns alle vorgibt und
doch das ist eine große Herausforderung
gallant hatte zuvor seine Truppen an der
Grenze zum Gazastreifen auf die nächste
Phase des Konflikts
eingeschwoben der Befehl wird kommen wir
vertrauen auf euch viel Glück wer immer
Gaza aus der Ferne sieht wird es von
innen zu sehen bekommen das verspreche
ich
euch einen Zeitpunkt für das mögliche
Vorrücken der Truppen nannte er
nicht und in Tel Aviv begrüße ich den
Bundesverteidigungsminister Herr
Pistorius guten
Tag ja schön guten Tag frauom sie waren
bevor sie nach telaviv gereist sind auch
bei der unifel also bei der UN mission
haben dort deutsche Soldaten auch
besucht die dort auf Mission sind und ja
inzwischen auch zwischen die Fronten
geraten sind es gab sogar einen
versehentlichen Raketeneinschlag wie
besorgt sind die deutschen Soldaten vor
Ort sie sind ähm entspannt angespannt so
würde ich es formulieren der
Raketeneinschlag der ganz offensichtlich
ein Irrläufer war äh und zwei Bomben mal
zwei raketenalarme letzte Nacht sorgen
natürlich dafür dass etwas Unruhe
aufkommt aber das sind wirklich pro
machen sich keine großen Sorgen weil sie
wissen dass sie nicht Ziel der Parteien
sind und dass sie auf die Zustände mit
denen Sie es zu tun haben gut
vorbereitet sind aber welche Sorgen
machen Sie sich welche Sorgen machen
sich die Militärs im Vorort über die
weitere Entwicklung der Lage gerade auch
mit Blick auf den Konflikt zwischen
Hisbollah und
Israel na ja das lieg auf der Hand die
ganze Welt blickt sorgenvoll auf diese
Region eine bevorstehende Boden
Offensive Israels ist das eine das ist
gedeckt vom Selbstverteidigungsrecht
nach dem Völkerrecht dass Israel zusteht
sie haben das Recht sich zu verteidigen
und ich will noch mal sagen nach den
Bildern die ich gesehen habe auch heute
hier wieder gesehen habe die Brutalität
die Grausamkeit mit der hier gegen
Zivilisten Kinder Frauen vorgegangen
worden ist ist unbeschreiblich und durch
nicht zu rechtfertigen das ist Blanka
Terror und deswegen haben hat haben die
israelischen Freunde das Recht sich zu
verteidigen und verdienen unsere
Solidarität und gleichzeitig blickt die
Welt eben sorgenvoll auf diese Region
weil natürlich jede Eskalation am Ende
auch ein nicht ein schwer kalkulierbares
Risiko mit sich bringt und deswegen es
ist gut dass der Bundeskanzler und gut
dass der amerikanische Präsident hier
sehr deutliche Worte gefunden haben auch
an die Akteure in der Region zur
Deeskalation beizutragen und Eskalation
zu vermeiden gehen sie denn nach ihren
Gesprächen davon aus dass es diese
Bodenoffensive nach wie vor geben wird
so ganz klar sicher war man sich da in
den letzten Tagen nicht mir auch mit
Blick auf die Warnungen die ja Joe Biden
ausgesprochen hat nicht die Fehler vom
11 September zu
wiederholen also ich habe nach wie vor
keinen Anlass daran zu zweifeln dass es
eine Bodenoffensive in welcher Form
Ausprägung auch immer geben wird äh die
Aufforderung an die Palästinenser im
Gazastreifen sich Richtung Süden zu
bewegen wird teilweise offenbar von der
Hamas nicht nur konkariert sondern auch
mit Gewalt verhindert dass Menschen in
den Süden ziehen äh natürlich macht
einem eine solche Bodenoffensive sorgen
aber sowohl mein Kollege jof Galland als
auch andere anderen Akteure und
Verantwortlichen hier haben mir
gegenüber als auch in den letzten Tagen
immer wieder deutlich gemacht dass sie
sich ihrer Verantwortung bewusst sind
zivile Opfer wo immer es irgendwie
möglich ist zu vermeiden aber wir wissen
alle wie schwer wie schwierig solche
Situationen sind und wie gefährlich sie
werden können die Situation ist ja jetzt
auch noch angespannter geworden
Stichwort zivile Opfer durch das durch
die Explosion an dem Krankenhaus in Gaza
die Israelis haben viele Dokumente
vorgelegt um zu belegen dass sie das
nicht waren wo steht Deutschland da
unterstützen Sie diese
Sicht ich habe keinen Zweifel an dieser
Darstellung zu zweifeln keinen Grund zu
zweifeln an dieser Darstellung wollte
ich sagen Entschuldigung
alles spricht dafür dass es nicht die
Israelis waren welchen Nutzen sollte
sollten die Israelis davon haben ein
ziviles krank enhaus zu zu anzugreifen
zu attackieren das ist völlig abseits
jeder Vorstellungskraft macht keinen
Sinn auch für das was Israel plant
Israel ist kein Terrorstaat die hamasse
ist die Terrororganisation und deswegen
muss man davon ausgehen dass es sich im
Zweifel tatsächlich um eine FE geleitete
Rakete gehandelt hat die zu diesen
tragischen Opfern geführt hat d heißt es
immer wieder die Sicherheit Israels sei
deutsche Staatsraison was würde das denn
im Falle eines Falles bedeuten auch an
militärische Hilfe würde man z.B darüber
nachdenken die corverte Oldenburg auf
der sie heute auch zu Besuch waren vor
die Küste gasas zu legen oder
ähnliches das ist im Augenblick nicht
Stand der Debatte die Anforderung
Israels sind bewegen sich in wirklich
marginalem Bereich von daher gibt es
zurzeit keinen Grund sich darüber
öffentlich Gedanken zu machen oder zu
spekulieren wir sind in engem Austausch
sowohl der Bundeskanzler mit dem
Ministerpräsidenten netanahu als auch
ich mit meinem gen hier aber aktuell
gibt es keine Anzeichen dafür dass so
etwas erforderlich werden könnte es gibt
mindestens einen der sich über diese
ganze Entwicklung freut der sitzt im
Kremmel in Moskau weil nun der Westen
nicht nur die Ukraine sondern auch
Israel unterstützen wird möglicherweise
auch sehr lange was bedeutet das für die
Unterstützung der
Ukraine zunächst überhaupt nichts weil
die Anforderung aus der Israel völlig
andere sind und noch sehr gering sind
und sich in anderen Bereichen bewegen
als das was die Ukraine von uns braucht
und bekommt von daher sehe ich diese
Konkurrenz aktuell nicht worauf wir
achten müssen ist in der Tat dass
angesichts der aktuellen Öffentlichkeit
aktuellen Aufmerksamkeit die Israel und
die Region hier gerade zurecht bekommen
das nicht aus dem Fokus gerät dass es
immer noch ein angriffsrieg Putins gegen
einen souveränen Staat mit in Europa
gibt den wir nicht aus dem Auge
verlieren dürfen und werden Herr
Pistorius danke ihn für das
Gespräch sehr gerne Frau
slamker das Interview hatten wir bereits
am Nachmittag aufgezeichnet bevor der
Verteidigungsminister den Rückflug
antrat und das war auch bevor bekannt
wurde dass der israelische
Verteidigungsminister sich zur
Bodenoffensive äußerte und einen
baldigen Beginn dieser Offensive
ankündigte W wir dazu zu unserem
Korrespondenten Michael beberungen Tel
Aviv schalten Michael nach diesen
Äußerungen des israelischen
Verteidigungsministers womit rechnet man
jetzt in
Israel also zur Stunde soll hier hinter
mir im Verteidigungsministerium das
kriegskabinett zusammengekommen sein um
über die Bodenoffensive zu beraten im
Lauf des Tages hatten premier Netanyahu
der Verteidigungsminister und andere
Politiker die Truppen im Süden besucht
dabei sind diese Sätze eben auch
gefollen gefallen die in nie dagewesener
Klarheit so deutlich von einer
Bodenoffensive und von einem beiligen
Beginn gesprochen haben das beendet die
die Unklarheit der letzten Tage wo
zuletzt spekuliert worden war ob diese
Bodenoffensive überhaupt noch
stattfinden wird sie wird stattfinden
offenbar wann ist schwer zu sagen aber
dass eben das Sicherheitskabinett
zusamment tritt deutet darauf hin dass
es sich nicht mehr um einen allzu großen
Zeitraum handeln wird zu den vielen
Fragen die sich da stellt gehört auch
was das für die Geiseln bedeuten
könnte ja die diese Fragen stellen sich
hier jeden Tag hunderte Menschen die
hier vor dem Verteidigungsministerium
demonstrieren sag bringt unsere Leute
unsere Angehörigen zurück das sind eben
die Angehörigen der Geiseln und die
machen sich natürlich große Sorgen es
gibt einen großen Teil der sagt lass
doch bitte alle Kriegshandlungen fallen
damit die Geiseln zurückkommen können
die Menschen sind natürlich verzweifelt
wenn es zu der bodenofensive kommt ist
es natürlich schwierig die Geiseln dann
mit Verhandlungen frei beekommen weil
die Verhandlungen dann erstmal auf
eisruhen könnten das wird dann auf
Kommandoaktionen hinauslaufen der
Israelis aber es ist auch unbekannt wo
sich die Geiseln aufhalten also das wird
sehr sehr schwierig das Leben der
Geiseln ist natürlich mit dieser
Bodenoffensive in weit aus höherer
Gefahr danke dir Michael nach Tel
Aviv und dann blicken wir nach
Deutschland Bundeskanzler Scholz hat
heute im Bundestag eine
Regierungserklärung abgegeben in der er
sich auch zur Lage im Nahen Osten und
zum Antisemitismus hier zulande
äußerte
Antisemitismus ist in Deutschland fehl
am Platze und wir werden alles dafür tun
ihn gegen ihn uns zu stellen es ist hier
auch eine klare Kante gefragt und wir
zeigen sie gemeinsam in
Deutschland er sagte das vor dem
Hintergrund der Ausschreitungen die es
auch letzte Nacht in Berlin wiedergab
omoman leskowa und Stefanie Heim
berichten es will keiner mit uns
sprechen Entschuldigung dürfen wir sie
was fragen Berlin Neuköln rund um die
Sonnenallee wir wollen wissen was die
Menschen hier bewegt nach zwei
krawallnächten inf Folge ist die Frage
was halten die die hier wohnen von
Protesten und Gewalt die wenigen die
Reden bewegen ganz unterschiedliche
Dinge ich möchte dass alles so friedlich
läuft mit Frieden also friedlich kann
man auch viel erreichen für Israel wird
alles gemacht aber für Gaza gar nichts
man darf sich gar nicht malr äußern und
ich das nicht richtig ist egal welche
Religion man hat egal welche
Nationalität Mensch ist Mensch da muss
man für alle Rechte suchen und nicht
dann immer sagen okay jetzt Israel oder
Gaza ist egal das ist Mensch ich wohne
hier in der Nähe ne da also abends
deswegen gucke ich auch immer wie spät
es ist abends möchte ich hier in dieser
Umgebung auch nicht mehr sein das regt
mich auf und finde ich auch bedrohlich
die ganze Situation letzte Nacht waren
die Ausschreitungen deutlich heftiger
als zuvor hunderte kamen genehmigt war
keine Demonstration nach letztem Stand
gab es 194 Freiheitsbeschränkungen dazu
zählt die Polizei 65 verletzte
Einsatzkräfte Stein und Flaschenwürfe
brennende Barrikaden die Stimmung
aggressiv es wird gesagt wir stehen
hinter Israel aber wer ist wir jeder
Mensch hat hier seine eigene Meinung und
teilweise die meisten Leute hier die
hier sind sind auf der Seite von
Palästina ich bin hier um meine Stimme
weiterzuleiten dass die Palästinenser
dort auch Menschenwürde haben im
neukölner Rathaus geht man von rund
20.000 palästinensischstämmigen
Bewohnern im Bezirk aus steineerfer
seien kaum erreichbar andere schon nicht
jeder der Verwandte und Bekannte in den
im Westjordanland oder am Gazastreifen
hat ist automatisch auch jemand der den
Staat Israel von einer Landkarte
radieren möchte so und diejenigen müssen
wir eben laut machen die müssen wir
unterstützen gerade in dieser jetzigen
Situation auch vor dem Auswärtigen Amt
wurde gestern protestiert
befreit Palästina von der deutschen
Schuld fordern Sie
hier die Palästinenser von deutscher
Schuld befreien wer solche Parolen ruft
hat anscheinend kein Problem damit
ähnlich wie die AFD zu klingen Stichwort
Schuldkult und ignoriert darüber hinaus
die sehr komplexen historischen
Hintergründe des
Nahostkonflikts scheint jedenfalls viele
Menschen zu geben die glauben dass in
den 1940er Jahren urplötzlich Juden ins
Heilige Land einfeh und den Arabern
ihren Palästinenserstaat wegnahmen dann
wissen sie offenbar wenig über die lange
Geschichte der Israeliten bei denen im
Laufe der Jahrtausende alle möglichen
Eroberer vorbeischauten darunter die
Babylonier Perser Griechen und Römer
sowie verschiedene arabische Dynastien
und schließlich die Osmanen von all
diesen Mächten haben einige zwar Juden
vertrieben aber keiner einen Staat
Palästina gegründet einen wachsenen
Zuzug jüdischer Siedler gab es dann
wieder seit im 19 Jahrhundert auch
aufgrund des weitverbreiteten
Antisemitismus in Europa und wie es
danach weiterging daran erinnert unsere
frühere narostkorrespondentin Nikola
Albrecht in einem kurzen historischen
Überblick vor dem Ersten Weltkrieg
gehören das heutige Israel das
Westjordanland und auch der Gazastreifen
zum Osmanischen Reich Juden und Araber
Leben weitestgehend friedlich zusammen
im Ersten Weltkrieg wird die Region die
damals Palästina heißt britisches
Mandatsgebiet viele Juden wandern zu
dieser Zeit dorthin aus Großbritannien
stellt sowohl Juden als auch den dort
ansässigen Arabern die Überlassung des
Landes in Aussicht infolge kommt es
zunehmend zu Konflikten zwischen Juden
Arabern und
Britten nach dem Holocaust sollen die
Juden einen eigenen Staat bekommen die
Vereinten Nationen wollen das britische
Mandatsgebiet teilen die Juden Stimmen
mehrheitlich zu die Araber lehnen den
Plan
ab am 14 mai 1948 ruft David bengurion
den Staat Israel aus mehrere arabische
Länder starten daraufhin einen Angriff
Israel gewinnt diesen Krieg und erobert
zusätzliche
Gebiete rund 750 000 der dortlebenden
Araber werden vertrieben oder fliehen
für viele von ihnen wird auch der
Gazastreifen zum Zufluchtsort nach dem
Krieg über nimt Ägypten die Verwaltung
in Gaza doch die Menschen bekommen keine
Pässe sie bleiben
statenlos
1977 greift Israel mit einem
Präventivschlag mehrere arabische
Nachbarstaaten an und kommt ihnen so
zuvor Israel siegt überwältigend und
besetzt neben dem Westjordanland
Ostjerusalem den Golanhöhen und dem
Sinai auch den
Gazastreifen in den besetzten Gebieten
siedeln in Folge immer me Juden laut UN
ein Verstoß gegen das
Völkerrecht 2005 räumt Israel den
Gazastreifen das Militär zieht ab und
die jüdischen Siedler müssen ihre
Wohnorte verlassen die verkürzte Formel
dafür lautet Land für Frieden sie geht
nicht
auf 2006 gewinnt die radikale Hamas die
Wahlen im Gazastreifen und reiß 2007 die
Macht gewaltsam an sich ihr Ziel Israel
vollständig vernichten und stattdessen
ein palästinens islamischen Staat
gründen damit grenzt sie sich auch von
der fatach ab der palästinensischen
Partei von Mahmut Abbas die das
Westjordanland regiert im Gegensatz zu
Hamas erkennt die fatach das
Existenzrecht Israels an und damit eine
mögliche
Zweistaatenlösung die
Schreckensherrschaft der Hamas trifft
auch die eigene Bevölkerung
Meinungsfreiheit gibt es nicht und die
Angriffe auf Israel nehmen zu Israels
Antwort Abriegelung und Blockade des
Gazastreifens seit 2005 gibt es immer
wieder schwere militärische
Auseinandersetzungen zwischen der Hamas
und Israel bis
heute die Aussage des Bundeskanzlers zu
Antisemitismus hatten wir ja eben schon
wiedergegeben Olaf Scholz hat sich heute
im Bundestag aber auch noch zu anderen
Themen geäußert und damit beginnen bei
dir die Nachrichten Halz ja in dieser
Regierungserklärung zum bevorstehen den
EU Gipfel ging er auch auf das Thema
Migration ein scholz sagte es müsse
getan werden was notwendig ist um es zu
schaffen dass die irreguläre Migration
nach Europa und nach Deutschland
begrenzt wird dass die Staaten sie
bewältigen können und die Kontrolle über
diese Situation behalten eine der großen
Aufgaben dabei sei der Schutz der
Außengrenzen
Europas der Bundestag hat eine Reform
des pflegestudiums beschlossen nach der
Studierende künftig eine Ausbild
Vergütung erhalten damit soll dieser
Ausbildungsweg attraktiver werden
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach sagte in
einer älter wdenden Gesellschaft würden
mehr junge Menschen benötigt die in der
Pflege arbeiten das Gesetz soll außerdem
Anerkennungsverfahren für ausländische
Pflegefachkräfte
vereinfachen nachdem bekannt geworden
ist dass am Montag ein neues Bündnis um
Sara Wagenknecht öffentlich vorgestellt
werden soll haben sich führende
Politiker der Linken zum weiteren vor
Vorgehen geäußert der
Fraktionsvorsitzende Barsch sagte er
habe alles versucht dass die Linke als
Fraktion zusammenbleibe jetzt werde es
eine neue eine andere konkurrenzpartei
geben die Linke Vorsitzende Wissler
forderte alle die eine neue Partei
gründen auf ihre Mandate
niederzulegen das Europaparlament ehrt
mit dem diesjährigen Sacharov
preispostum die Iranerin Gina Masha
Amini sowie die Frauenbewegung Frauen
Leben Freiheit in Iran die brutale
Ermordung der 22-jährigen amenie sei ein
Wendepunkt und habe eine frauengeführte
Bewegung ausgelöst die Geschichte
schreibe so eu-parlamentspräsidentin
metzolan amen war im vergangenen Herbst
wegen eines angeblichen Verstoßes gegen
die islamische Kleiderordnung
festgenommen worden und in
Polizeigewahrsam gestorben ihr Tod hatte
landesweite Proteste gegen Irans Regime
und dessen Sittengesetze ausgelö
Boris Pistorius sagt im Interview mit
mir vorhin ja dass die Unterstützung der
Ukraine nicht darunter leiden soll dass
es nun einen weiteren Krieg gibt der den
Westen in Atem hält das können die
Ukrainer nur hoffen tatsache ist jedoch
dass sich die Aufmerksamkeit der
Weltöffentlichkeit derzeit auf den Nahen
Osten richtet während in der Ukraine die
Kämpfe weitergehen mit hohen Verlusten
auf beiden Seiten an der südlichen Front
bei herson versuchen die Ukrainer
offenbar über den Fluss nipre
vorzustoßen was die Russen mit allen
Mitteln verhindern wollen Anne brül
berichtet aus der
Ukraine sie fliehen weil sie es nicht
länger ertragen können die russischen
Angriffe auf die Stadt Ron und ihre
Vororte Alena lach ist mit drei ihrer
Enkelkindern auf dem Weg raus in
Sicherheit ältere Schwester wurde
verletzt er wurde beschossen war voller
Blut erint wenn er daran erinnert seine
Beine wurden von schrapnellen
getroffen täglich feuert russische
Artillerie schlagen Bomben ein Ziel ist
seit Monaten vor allem die
Zivilbevölkerung wir gehen hier raus
weil wir keine Kraft mehr haben ich weiß
nicht was ich machen soll sie
bombardieren Tag und
Nacht im Blutspendezentrum in Kiev
stehen sie Schlange für die Verletzten
dieses Kriegs für Zivilisten und
Soldaten Anastasia kommt Monate erzählt
sie
uns ich spende Blut Spende manchmal auch
Geld ich tue alles was ich kann damit
wir so schnell wie möglich diesen Krieg
gewinnen jetzt verlieren wir so viele
Menschen viele verlieren so viel Blut
man muss diese Verluste
ausgleichen Blutspenden für die die ihr
Land verteidigen seit Beginn des
russischen angriffri hatah Spenden in
der Ukraine um 60%
zugenommen angefangen hat es am 24
Februar wir sehen seitdem dass wir jetzt
mehr Blutspender haben sie wissen dass
ihr Blut für einen guten Zweck verwendet
wird wir haben jetzt einen großen
Bedarf vor dem Krieg hat das Zentrum vor
allem Krankenhäuser beliefert jetzt geht
vieles von hier gleich an die Front
Anastasia ist ein bisschen nervös aber
überzeugt das Richtige zu tun Blut sagt
sie sei persönlichste was sie geben
könnte das ist ein Symbol der Liebe und
der
Fürsorge Hilfe für Soldaten für die
Opfer in einem Krieg dessen Ende nicht
absehbar
ist und jetzt geht's bei dir noch mal
weiter im saahand gab es heute einen
stahlaktionstag mehrere tausend Menschen
demonstrierten für die Zukunft ihrer
Jobs hintergrund ist der Umbau der
Stahlproduktion hin zu grüner Energie
und jetzt Fr geht es um Förderzusagen ja
seit Monaten wartet die
saarstahlindustrie auf grünes Licht aus
Berlin und aus Brüssel aber die
Fördergelder kommen nicht und nun drängt
aus Sicht der Saarländer die Zeit
deshalb also dieser stahlaktionstag
heute an der Kundgebung in Dillingen
sollen am Vormittag über 5000 Menschen
teilgenommen haben weitere große
Protestmärsche fanden statt unter
anderem in Völklingen im vergangenen
Jahr haben die Saarländer einen 3,5
Milliarden Euro schweren Umbau planan
vorgelegt mit dem man ab 2027 jährlich
bis zu 3,5 Millionen Tonnen CO2 am Stahl
produzieren und damit 4,9 Millionen
Tonnen CO2 einsparen möchte ohne förder
zu sagen aber geht gar nichts die
Saarländer also warten auf eine
verbindliche Unterstützung zur
Herstellung von klimafreundlichen Stahl
Zusagen die Wettbewerber bereits
erhalten haben tüsen Grup hatte von der
EU-Kommission bereits im julai das Jahr
für Gelder und Höhe von bis bis zu 2
Milliarden Euro erhalten auch die
Salzgitter AG hat bereits einen
Förderbescheid über rund 1 Milliarde
Euro bekommen das Saarland braucht jetzt
schnellst möglich Klarheit weil daran
tausende von Jobs hängen Frank betetmann
vielen Dank
gerne die
ostseeküstenregionen in Deutschland
sowie in Teilen Dänemarks und Schwedens
müssen sich auf Sturmfluten mit
Hochwassergefahr einstellen eine schwere
Sturmflut wird in Schleswig-Holstein
erwartet er ist der Ausläufer spülten
bereits Wasser auf die Promenade in
Travemünde in MecklenburgVorpommern
haben einige fairlinien teilweise oder
ganz den Betrieb eingestellt in Dänemark
haben die Behörden Bewohner und Urlauber
aufgefordert das Küstengebiet im Süden
und Osten bis morgen früh zu
verlassen so viel vom heute journal
gleich geht es bei Maybrit ner weiter
die mit ihren Gästen heute auch über die
Lage im Nahen Osten spricht um 030 Uhr
gibt's dann unser heute schonal Update
mit Laura BEK und hier begrüßen sie
morgen abend Anne gellineek und hez Wolf
auf Wiedersehen auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen schön guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter ein
Sturmtief hat uns erreicht und das
bedeckt fast ganz Europa sehen es hier
die Windrichtung an den Küsten ist
ungewöhnlich kommt aus Ost und ist sehr
hoch die Windgeschwindigkeiten teils
orkanartige Böhne und dazu Regen der von
Südwesten nach Norden zieht was den Wind
betrifft wird an der Küste hier Richtung
kielerbucht und lübeckerbucht bis zu 2 m
mehr erwartet das Wasser steigt also
deutlich über das Mittel und was es noch
gibt ist Föhnsturm an den Alpen und
Sturm ist hier tatsächlich untertrieben
es sind Böhen bis zu 140 km pro St
Stunde möglich und das bei belaubten
Bäumen die sind ja noch relativ grün und
haben einen hohen Widerstand gegen den
Wind können also Umfallen wir schauen
auf die Nacht und da gibt's viel Regen
der immer wieder Richtung Norden zieht
viel Wind an den Küsten der sich aufbaut
ganz im Süden da ist es teilweise
aufgelockert mit Fön ja und die
Temperaturen sinken auf 4° im Osten und
13° ganz im Westen Deutschlands morgen
mehr Regen der durchzieht und ja die
Situation an den Küsten hier mit viel
Wind und teils hohen Wellen ganz im
Süden da ist eben auch dieser Föhnsturm
dabei Temperaturen maximal 6° im Osten
und 22° mit föunterstützung ganz im
Süden Deutschlands Samstag ist es noch
ruppig aber ab Sonntag wird's dann
ruhiger und vor allem Montag ist es dann
relativ sonnig damit einen schönen Abend